le jeudi à tisse barrer nous propose une
chronique sur le bien-être animal alors
ATIS on va parler d'une carte elle
s'affiche elle va s'afficher à l'écran
c'est inscrit j'ai un animal seul à la
maison alors en quoi ça consiste
concrètement à titre alors nous sommes
au mois de janvier c'est le mois où
c'est pas un mois très gai le taux de
mortalité est à son pic les malaises on
sort des fêtes on attrape plutôt des
infections par exemple vous attendez
votre train à jour de grève un malaise
peut vite arriver bouffée de chaleur
vous êtes transporté par les pompiers et
vous ne savez pas quand est-ce que vous
allez rentrer
donc cette carte votre animal va vous
attendre seule à la maison pendant des
heures et des longues heures et il ne
s'est pas encore lire et écrire et
pourra pas voir vos textos et donc du
coup cette carte elle sert à prévenir
les gens autour de nous mais qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire alors en fait cette
carte elle va éviter à votre animal de
d'avoir un risque de déjà d'être dans un
état de d'anxiété puisque les animaux
également on peuvent avoir une atteinte
psychologique cette carte donc j'ai créé
au niveau de la ville de Poissy qui se
présente comme celle-ci j'ai un animal
seul à la maison va vous permettre de
noter donc déjà le type d'animal est-ce
que c'est un chat un chien un acte les
nouveaux animaux de compagnie votre
lapin votre souris et dessus vous allez
y mettre donc les cordonnées de votre
gardien par exemple qui a les clés de
chez vous vous mettrez son nom son
numéro de téléphone et dès que donc vous
la mettez dans votre portefeuille dès
que les services sont bons ouvrez votre
portefeuille ils seront un animal qui
est à la maison et qu'il prévienne donc
vos parents vos enfants et surtout ça va
également éviter des nuisances au niveau
du voisinage car croyez-moi que je suis
très souvent appelée pour dire qu'un
chien qui pleure à la maison que fait-on
on fait intervenir la police qu'est-ce
qui se passe alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait
sinon on entend un chien qui qui crie
chez lui enfin qu'est-ce qu'on comment
est-ce qu'on intervient bah déjà en fait
on appelle vous appelez votre alors ça
dépend des villes vous avez des
quartiers vous faites une petite enquête
de voisinage qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
les voisins sont là sont pas là j'ai eu
le cas il y a deux semaines
donc ensuite ils ont réussi à appeler un
proche qui est arrivé sinon c'est la
police qui défonce la porte qui fait
intervenir avec le maître chien qui voit
si l'animal est bonne condition sinon on
prend on récupère l'animal
pour terminer ATIS cette carte on peut
la trouver où la récupérer où alors
cette carte vous pouvez la récupérer
dans certaines mairies à la mairie de
Poissy au niveau de l'accueil dans
d'autres mairies également bon pas dans
toutes les mairies et puis au niveau des
CCAS merci beaucoup à Athis on vous
retrouve dans deux semaines c'est bien
ça